ey amelie it's all so on my nerves here
no party does what i want yes
then also found your own
no bad idea actually and how does that work
first you need an event
the so-called founding party conference at which a name
a board of directors consisting of three persons
a program and a statute are adopted
ersatzung in ersatzung stands for example
where the headquarters of the party is okay
in addition,
the party must be in the register of clubs
be registered
you only need seven members for that i can do it
this is done
you send the documents to the federal election official
After an exam
then the federal election committee will decide
whether your party will be allowed to vote
but then you already need n few
more members
how many so approximately
this is not quite precisely defined
important is in any case
that they live all over germany
and form country lists
to be able to run in the federal election later on
after approval
your party must then in every state
Collect signatures of voters
that support them
all this is done
then your party could actually be elected
sounds somehow too exhausting but